[Music]
okay
i'm gonna posture up
and you're not gonna let me posture up
okay
all right so you don't you don't want me
posturing up because i'm gonna
knock the hell out okay so when you feel
me go up nope
okay you're not gonna be strong enough
though grab it
okay so as i go up
grab
bridge knee bump down
okay
then so let's work on that timing
so okay here boom on
follow with the grab oh
that's it
i have to do my roll okay i got to do my
role as the
suspect okay so
there you go okay
so she goes
and work the overhook and the head
clinch
leg trap bridge
up inside push down distance
don't move stay on the ground
um i'm gonna hook the head
i'm gonna spread my face out okay
i don't know i'm gonna be particularly
aware of what she's doing
on that gun side okay so when i feel her
her hand go do you see that i must step
up
like this step up and pull
down on my arm you see how i'm doing
that so i'm gonna let go of that head
hook
just to keep that arm there and i'm just
driving
way into our face
boom pay attention face out if she's
leaving her around there i'm going to
end him oh i feel that hand starts to
move i'm going to change
this way and get that trapped okay
you're gonna have to posture up because
if you stay down you're actually taking
weight off of her
so i'm putting my weight this way
pelvis down okay okay
so go ahead different from
uh there was a i have a weapon on me
okay
so as i come through um
the ones that i was showing i didn't
catch her arm you see
her arms underneath me so i'm aware of
it
when she starts when i feel her going
down
i might not be able to get the underhook
at this point
so instead i'm going to come up with my
leg do you see this way
we'll bring her in this way
if i can get the underhook early then
i'm going to keep the underhook
so i'm coming through and i'm going to
keep the under hood pieces
i keep that under hood and anchor it
away
from her so here
i'm using the side of her neck
to anchor if i want i can forfeit some
base
to keep it but i'm here
keeping it up tight so she can't get the
one
all right let's work the over hook so
she's coming
on all posture oh
come on we're to work this overhook this
overhook right here
okay so boom
my reversal i'm going to keep it
to see how i'm keeping it like this
okay about reversal
come in and drive it
down into this threaded position
okay here
oh through keeping it this way
my arm has to lengthen okay you feel
that the knot curled here
has to lengthen to keep it tight i move
off the side
drive it down this way
to the thread other arm off
okay stop them from rolling
this way you just keep your arm there so
they don't roll
but it's not so easy to roll you can
also go this way
and you have it okay
when you do this uh
your weight is actually off her back
not on her back it's loose right now
right
off her back into the arm hand goes
towards the feet
and you basically have the same
technique
on both sides the weight's not on her
back since you're on
getting on try to feel the energy
that goes up come down with it i won't
see there's pressure there
oh now i'm holding them
maybe i'm trying the oopa i can't get it
maybe the person has started to stop
aggressing or assaulting but i'm not
going to let them
go or maybe my backup gets there on time
so in comes my backup they're going to
get the free arm two on one
and you're going to walk it around the
head
as i do the uppa nope
you're going to walk it around the head
as i do the
here we go walk around
i'm going to do the last technique
you're going to walk back around the
head
pull it and we're gonna go
to two-man cuffing okay we'll do it
again
got it walk around
walk around in
to america
got it walk around
walk around